I do not want to end on a somber
fatalistic note because frankly it is
not what I think
although the political scenario of the
liberal Democratic West worries me
I believe that like in the past
all that is healthy idealistic and
generous
and that has to do with love for freedom
in the Western World will eventually
react and Prevail over those who want to
end it
since I am a writer of fiction before a
political essayist
I will now tell you a story
exactly as it happened
I am not changing the subject here
although it may at first seem so
a few years ago in late December
2004 a tsunami hit the coast of Kenya
which devastated lives and homes
destroyed Villages and forests and
caused major economic upheaval in the
African country
one of the victims was a hippopotamus
named Owen
he was just a few months old and weighed
300 kilos
the Raging Waters had swept him along
the length of the sabaki river and
hurled him into the Indian Ocean
there the choppy waves and currents
driven Wild by the storm threw him back
onto land
leaving him stranded and no doubt
terrified and exhausted on the outskirts
of Mombasa
fortunately some volunteers from the
LaFarge Park natural reserve which stood
next to that Kenyan Port found him
they worked to calm him and help him
regain its strength
but they could not bring back his mother
who predictably perished in the
cataclysm
hippopotamuses are very family oriented
and calves stay close to their parents
during the first four years of life
not want to miss an opportunity Owen the
orphan quickly found an adoptive mother
to replace the one he had lost
ecologist
Paola kahumu who manages LaFarge Park
was surprised to learn that among the
females of the reserve Owen had chosen
for his maternal function for this
maternal function a large 100 year old
turtle
which was already assuming her duties
with affection and responsibility
since then mother and child have become
inseparable
they swim eat and sleep together
anytime anyone man or beast approaches
the turtle the normally peace law in
Owen becomes enraged and launches Us
North that is scatter as the birds from
nearby trees
this tender story does not surprise me
much many years ago I was teaching at
George Washington University in San Luis
Missouri
across from the apartment building where
I lived was a lovely Zoo where I would
walk in the mornings
there I met a newborn hippopotamus pink
ugly silly and delightful
with whom I got along very well
he must have guessed my long-standing
weakness for hippopotamuses because I
swear he seemed glad to see me each day
when I approached it to say good morning
played with his mother splashing in the
water as she opened her enormous trap to
give him some noisy leakings of maternal
off
hippopotamuses are benign defenseless
hedonistic and dreamy creatures
like hippies they like to Make Love Not
War
their entanglements when made when
mating are spectacular I can assure you
to watch them join in an Amorous twist
the unaware good thing they were trying
to kill one other but in reality they
are thoroughly enjoying themselves
it is thrilling to watch them roll in
the mat with childish Joy or to wait for
hours with infinite patience for some
hummingbird or butterfly to fly into
their mouths and thus to add a touch of
seasoning to their herbivore diet since
their narrow trouts permit them to
swallow only various small fish and
birds
I am also quite fond of turtles both
large and small land and Aquatic
once I witnessed them in the 1970s
spawning on a little beach along the
maranon river on a Moonlight night in
the Amazons
it was a delicate and beautiful
spectacle
I try to give my younger son a turtle
once
Gonzalo was such an urban child that
when he held the little animal in his
hands he tried to rub it against the
floor several times to make it go like a
window cup
the slow creature sometimes disappear
among the bougainvilleas and ferns of
the garden for days at a time
it could go for hours without sticking
out his blurry eye little head from its
shell
but when he did attracted by a piece of
lettuce or a cracker it would chew with
infinite calm as its eye shown with an
unviable light of appreciation wisdom
and contentment for life
the poor thing came to a tragic and
we went on a trip and when we returned a
week later we founded that
fit up
we never try to find out which of the
children in the house had put it in that
position without suspecting that it
could not write itself alone
story of Owen and his adoptive mother
has a moral of course
it is not a disgrace that the two
animals belonging to species as distant
starters and hippopotamuses could
coexist relate to one another and love
one another whereas a stupid stupid
human bypets servicely kill each other
as soon as they discover frequently in
significant differences between them
if one looks back at the wars genocides
and bloodiest killings of recent years
one discover one will discover that the
homicidal passions behind the world's
Collective tragedies occur among very
close communities blood brothers whose
rivalries Steam from distinctions of
religious Doctrine political ideology
ideology or ethnic Customs that are
esoteric for those who do not live
within their midst